>> Will Sentance: Vì vậy, lập trình cặp.
Không có cách nào tốt hơn để phát triển như một kỹ sư phần mềm.
Lý do là, chúng tôi đã nói ở phần đầu, khi mọi người chia sẻ các tài nguyên như Pluralsight.
Chính Sean đã chia sẻ điều đó.
Pluralsight được điều khiển bằng video.
Những nguồn lực này là vững chắc.
Chúng rất xuất sắc.
Chà, tôi không yêu Pluralsight nhiều như Frontend Masters,
một trong những tài nguyên tốt nhất cho video.
Chà, nó là tốt nhất trong một chặng đường dài.
Đối với thực tế, nó rõ ràng là tốt nhất.
Nhưng những thứ đó chỉ hợp pháp nếu bạn đang sử dụng chúng,
sử dụng chúng để giải quyết các vấn đề bạn đang gặp phải trong công việc hàng ngày.
Vì vậy, nếu bạn là một kỹ sư đầy tham vọng và bạn không làm việc trên JavaScript khó
vấn đề hàng ngày, sau đó bạn rơi vào cái bẫy của cái mà tôi gọi là học dễ dàng.
Học dễ dàng là học mà bạn không đạt được các khối và do đó bạn không phát triển.
Vậy làm cách nào để bạn thực hiện điều mà tôi gọi là học chăm chỉ mà hiệu quả
đó thực sự là điều khiến bạn phát triển như một kỹ sư?
Chà, bạn làm những việc như thử thách lập trình khó khăn.
Bạn xây dựng các dự án.
Bạn có bài tập.
Nhưng vấn đề với những thứ đó là quá hấp dẫn để làm gì?
Để làm bất cứ điều gì khác ngoài điều đó.
Bao gồm, vì vậy chúng tôi có thể đang pha một tách trà.
Bất cứ điều gì.
Nhưng ngay cả khi nó không phải thế, ngay cả khi người kia thích, không, không,
Tôi thực sự có thể vượt qua chúng.
Bạn vẫn có thể rơi vào hai cái bẫy.
Tôi gọi nó là nhà nghiên cứu so với Stack Overflower.
Đây là nhà nghiên cứu.
Đó là kính lúp của tôi.
Tôi cần phải đánh vần điều đó rất tiếc vì rõ ràng tôi đã được nói
không ai nhận ra biểu tượng này là gì.
Và một Stack Overflower.
Lý tưởng nhất, là một kỹ sư phần mềm, chúng tôi luôn cân bằng hai thái cực này.
Tôi muốn hiểu mọi thứ và cách nó hoạt động, nhưng
Tôi đồng thời phải làm cho nó hoạt động đôi khi.
Chỉ làm cho nó hoạt động mà không cần hiểu từng mảnh.
Chúng tôi luôn cân bằng hai nhu cầu này.
Là một kỹ sư chuyên nghiệp đối mặt với những thử thách khó khăn,
chúng tôi hy vọng đã học cách cân bằng điều đó một cách hiệu quả.
Nhưng chúng tôi luôn có thể làm tốt hơn nó,
và cách tốt nhất tôi biết để có được sự cân bằng là lập trình cặp.
Ghép nối lập trình, bằng cách tách các mối quan tâm.
Một mặt chúng ta có James, mặt khác, chúng ta có Phước lành.
James và Blessing đang cùng nhau vượt qua thử thách.
Giả sử Blessing được gọi là hoa tiêu của chúng ta, và James là người lái xe của chúng ta.
Ban phước không bao giờ được phép gõ.
Cô ấy không được phép đặt tay lên bàn phím.
Nhưng cô ấy chịu trách nhiệm giải quyết vấn đề của thử thách.
Điều đó có nghĩa là, Blessing là người sẽ nói ra và
tiếp cận cả chiến lược tổng thể và thực thi từng dòng của mã
mà James sau đó sẽ diễn giải thành mã thực tế.
Cô ấy sẽ không bao giờ kiểm soát bàn phím.
Cô ấy sẽ không bao giờ chỉ nói, James, bạn không phiền nếu tôi chỉ cho bạn biết ý tôi chứ?
>> [ÂM THANH].
>> Will Sentance: Thay vào đó, mối quan tâm về sự chia ly này sẽ đảm bảo rằng phước lành
không thể trở thành một nhà nghiên cứu trong mười giờ, đọc mọi điều cuối cùng về
từ khóa mới vì cô ấy có James ngồi đó đợi.
Nhưng cô ấy cũng không thể chỉ là một Stack Overflower, làm cho nó hoạt động, cắm và
đóng vai người viết kịch bản vì James cần biết thêm một chút về lý do tại sao chúng tôi làm việc đó.
Chiến lược của chúng tôi ở đây là gì?
Chúng ta đang làm gì từng dòng một?
Nhưng cô ấy cũng không được phép nói, James,
hãy để tôi chỉ cho bạn, giao tiếp kỹ thuật của cô ấy, khả năng
cô ấy giải thích cách tiếp cận của mình và làm cho nó có ý nghĩa đối với người khác là điều quan trọng.
Đó là điều chúng tôi tìm kiếm trong các đoạn mã phỏng vấn nhiều hơn là [KHÔNG NGHE ĐƯỢC].
Chúng tôi đã từ chối nhiều người cho Codesmith, những người từng là kỹ sư JavaScript
trong bốn hoặc năm năm, bởi vì giao tiếp kỹ thuật của họ không có ở đó.
Và đó là điều tạo nên một nhà phát triển cao cấp.
Nhà phát triển cấp trung, lấy bất kỳ tính năng nào, triển khai nó.
Ngay cả khi họ chưa từng thấy khái niệm này trước đây,
bởi vì họ đã học cách vượt qua các khối.
Nhà phát triển cấp cao có thể sử dụng bất kỳ tính năng nào và họ có thể trao quyền cho nhóm,
đồng nghiệp của họ, để thực hiện nó, bởi vì khả năng của họ
mô hình tinh thần bên trong của họ về mã và làm cho nó có ý nghĩa đối với người khác.
Đó là những gì chúng tôi đang đào tạo khi chúng tôi ghép nối chương trình.
Được rồi, có nghĩa là một máy giữa hai.
Nó có nghĩa là chuyển đổi vai trò cứ sau mười phút hoặc lâu hơn.
Nhân tiện, nó có nghĩa là nếu đối tác của bạn đang đi theo con đường mà bạn cho là sai lầm,
để nó đi đến điểm mà họ nhấn chạy.
Và họ thấy lỗi và sau đó cùng nhau gỡ lỗi.
Đừng nói, tôi nghĩ bạn đã đi sai đường ở đây.
Rất, rất hiệu quả.
Được rồi, mọi người.
Đây rồi.
Bạn sẽ truy cập csbin.io.
Điều này dành cho thế giới tiêu điểm trực tuyến của chúng tôi.
Bạn đang truy cập csbin.io/promises.
Tiếp cận nó, bắt đầu làm việc với chúng và chúng tôi sẽ sớm kết nối lại.